>> THE MEDIA WAS CRITICAL OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S HANDLING OF
AFGHANISTAN.
NOW SOME ARE PROVIDING COVER FOR
THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF,
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO A
CALL WITH THE FORMER AFGHAN
PRESIDENT.
CHRIS HAYES SAYS FAKE IT TO YOU
MAKE IT IS A SAD STATEMENT ON
CUE -- CUMULATIVE FAILURES.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS COMMENTARY
FOR THE PRESIDENT FACING
CRITICISM FOR LEAVING AMERICANS
BEHIND IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> PEOPLE SHOULD STOP BEATING UP
ON THE ADMINISTRATION SO MUCH.
NO MATTER HOW IT ENDED,
EVERYBODY WASN'T GOING TO BE
HAPPY.
YOU CAN'T GET THEM ALL OUT IN
FIVE MINUTES.
YOU CAN'T GET THEM ALL OUT
YESTERDAY.
SO WHAT HAPPENS GOING FORWARD,
WE CONTINUE WITH THIS EFFORT TO
GET THEM OUT AND WE START
GETTING THEM OUT AS MANY AS
POSSIBLE, THEN I THINK WE SHOULD
STOP RUNNING AROUND OH, MY GOSH,
I CAN'T BELIEVE WE LEFT THEM
EHIND.